muy contento fueron las primeras
palabras del expresidente catalán carles
puigdemont a la salida del tribunal de
sassari en la isla de cerdeña italia la
corte de apelación suspendió la decisión
de extradición hasta que la corte
europea resuelva sobre la inmunidad del
líder independentista y sobre la
competencia de la justicia española para
emitir una orden de arresto
se ha suspendido el proceso contra el
presidente puigdemont ahora puede viajar
como le plazca
es un hombre libre para toda europa
excepto en españa' puigdemont fue
detenido el 23 de septiembre en el
puerto de cerdeña y va a asistir a un
festival cultural catalán invitado por
el movimiento independentista sardo
su detención fue por una orden del
tribunal supremo español aunque fue
liberado al día siguiente tanto a
puigdemont como clara ponsatí y toni
comín los otros dos eurodiputados
independentistas el tribunal general de
la unión europea les había retirado la
inmunidad ya que consideraba que no
había riesgo de arresto tras la decisión
but the moon retoma sus obligaciones
parlamentarias esta tarde podría seguir
la sesión del europarlamento de manera
telemática desde algar porque la
justicia sardá ha suspendido el
procedimiento de extradición en octubre
de 2017 el gobierno de cataluña celebre
un referendo de secesión y llegó a
declarar durante ocho segundos la
independencia la respuesta judicial del
estado español provocó la salida de
medio gobierno en su mayoría a bélgica
la otra mitad fue encarcelada junto a
dos líderes sociales este año recibieron
el indulto actualmente el gobierno de
españa y de cataluña se encuentran en
reuniones de una mesa de diálogo que
busca el fin del conflicto